I'm gonna take my keys out don't want
people to think I have a dick hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the don't laugh challenge not
the try log of the blue so this is the
don't laugh challenge which means that
we are gonna have water in our mouth and
they're gonna try to make me laugh and
then I'm gonna try to make em laugh
and then we're gonna try to make ham lab
this season by the way hi I don't think
we've ever formally introduced him hi
I'm Ethan
yeah he's Ethan this time and just
instead of water we have water anyway so
that's not important what is important
is that we're here to not laugh and so
are you guys because that's probably
what's gonna happen right already
okay go nope
and it was a bad idea to put peanuts at
the top of us
I remember megwin and Lessman with that
data on blaring waiters your leave you
we're going to the schnitzel star Oh
coach put me in we put it in got all the
everybody cookin - you boys ready
I was almost breaking not because of
what you did because every time it
didn't work you guys but I shouldn't put
a dick in front of his hat and that's
really annoying huh oh well better suck
it for gonna make America great yeah
yeah
chumps gonna make America great again
hmm think I need a turn the carpets is
just damn it
I've lost the fastest milers lost the
slowest but still awesome and even we
don't know what he do we want to make
predictions call it place your bets
right now don't skip ahead price your
[ __ ] you when you would have you
anything actually mailing it right to me
were you having the started in your free
this bad guys we've respect you gotta
respect bed you gotta respect the badge
you gotta respect every party Daniel yes
indeed what I got you man oh just a sip
a super see I never had a spicy [ __ ]
like it that's good for you know gonna
talk to mister
Oh who's it doesn't matter dad for some
reason you thought this German German
colonial guy no no no she tomato balls
burger burgers burgers woman got a ride
back now you Damon
damn bro he was like dripping oh you
were so close right then in there
alright anyway so now my turn again see
we do this better I wish my wife weren't
dead she died pretty fast
she done by of it I was trying to get it
to whip me stop you're getting it on the
carpet alright so the new score is
oh did somebody finish Thank You booth
nobody okay can you help me find my dad
son no can you help me son yeah yeah do
you know that's not a requirement to do
that it's small it could swallow all
right three two one go
this is a step up ha ha don't look at my
face because it's not making it there
but your magic if this was only lucky
body sticker book give me the body
Oh heaven baby Wow as the wise man once
said never wasted opportunity when it
presents itself you'll be the one to
overlook any personal satisfaction there
is nothing more terrible than wasted
potential in your life
ah yo you gonna give me three number
three you're such a beauty god you're
such a good girl
I'm just shove the head Israel she
wanted it she's calling me a thorn or is
a uh which means that it's all tied up
right so we got yeah I I won and lost
Tyler won a lost you lost and what lost
hang one want to know what you wanted
lost he lost him one I lost in one
technically I lost the quick note I
maybe you know we've all broken
we've unbroken once yeah we've all
broken once so we're going to go through
an ultimate tiebreaker round
yep no holds barred except so no
touching so exactly the same bars being
held in this round okay so for the final
lightning round we're going to mix up
the order a bit it's going to be even
first even higher
mr. chase mr. Jane is DJ how you doing
mr. Jackie really Billy a peck on the
cheek mr. Jay please oh Jesus mr. Jack
see with this bad rep since you see
Ethan score accumulated through all the
rounds some stupid
okay all right now that that's clear I
Donald J Trump will build the best wall
the world will have the best healthcare
that the world has ever seen mr. J - ha
ha ha ha
we've got the biggest views the best
people say I have small hands that's a
lie
look at my giant hands and from that you
can infer I have a chubby you got a nice
push on you it went back to work at the
whorehouse yeah Oh everybody I'm
markiplier god damn ah if you would have
said subscribe - markiplier it would
have been dog want to prison but Eva's
just does their hello I'm Margo
nothing's working Tyler we've got to go
to drastic measures I've got the biggest
day so it's a tie between me and you huh
so now it's a face-off yeah ok ok since
I was the woman we're making up [ __ ]
as we go almost since I've left faster
the first time if I don't make him laugh
in this one I lose for whatever I don't
know but I
America at all you're off to pee buddy
did you do any crimes huh yeah see
anyone doing bad or here no all right in
three one Jesus right ah crazy I have a
trump supporter her Jesus cries Li out
thank you well done
well good well I mean all right you did
okay
chica release was this an american at
all all right so now is that don't laugh
challenge hope you guys enjoyed that we
had a lot of fun with it if you did and
want to see more let us know down in the
comments below thank you again everybody
for watching thank you to either no
doubt movie and as always we'll see you
in the next video
you
I've got a pretty skanky puss